I also want to make the point and I'm
going to make the prediction here and I
don't think it's going it's the kind of
prediction people are first like then
they think about like okay this is
actually an easy good prediction I think
the democrat's plan B is not Gavin mome
I think the democrat's plan B is Hillary
Clinton with nuum as VP so I'm I'm
saying it right here if they pull Biden
for some reason or if he's incapacitated
they're going to run Hillary and they'd
be smart to do it $1,000 it will not be
Hillary Clinton uh that if if Biden's
pulled I I'm not making a real bad I'm
kidding
making a reference to I got got I felt
like they were kind of teeing up Kamala
Harris there's no way they tee Kamala
Harris I I I don't know why they would
pick her but because they're sending her
on this national pro-abortion tour she's
basically already on the camp because
they don't want her making trouble in
Washington they like stay busy I'm
serious did you see the uh she's going
out tour they announced one date they're
like we'll tell you the rest of the get
out of here the latest the latest clip
from her where she's like this is the
most election we've had in you know in
our lifetimes and I'm just like uh